when I was growing up IBM was the
monolith and it was always okay are we
gonna beat him are we gonna join him
those bastards
you're probably wondering what is this
woman
wearing a cat suit on Evan Carmichael's
channel and this is where you start this
is where you start making it happen it's
all in the now rise and shine it's in
spresso time what some believe nation
it's Lily here and my one word is
extraordinary I believe that every
single one of you is capable of
extraordinary when you embrace who you
truly are so let's start your morning
off right together go grab yourself a
cup of coffee and sip on today's message
make it happen over to you Bill Gates
the idea that computers were going to be
a change agent and I was lucky enough to
meet Paul Allen and early on we
brainstormed about this I did the chip
and the chip changed the rules I mean
most things don't get a million times
better not you know
engine efficiency or you know most
things have theoretical minimums
computation is something that we're not
even close to the theoretical minimum
and yet we've improved so much so seeing
that that was going to come and weirdly
that most people didn't see that was
going to come so you know even people at
IBM were still thinking in terms of big
computers you know now all the the
software and service driven companies
are worth even more than IBM when I was
growing up I'd be endless the monolith
and it was always okay are we gonna beat
him are we gonna join him those bastards
actually that were very nice people but
we always thought of them and they they
sort of stood for these big computers
that only big companies and governments
could get the benefit for so actually we
played off of that have this power to
the people personal computing type thing
of course now we're a big company and
somebody can play off of us the idea
that a young person could start a
company here is a super nice thing
because although people at first are
skeptical as soon as they realized their
normal model of what I knew and what I
could do that I didn't fit that normal
model then they assumed I knew way more
than I did and I could solve all sorts
of problems I had no clue you know how
to solve but you know it was nice that
people were kind of a GOG that we'd
built this company and done these things
from a young age so I think the culture
of America that you know almost the
American Dream type success story worked
out I believe that not enough people are
making it happen whatever the it means
for you whether if it's starting a
business starting a YouTube channel or
even traveling the world you're so
afraid that people are gonna judge you
for doing the things that you really
want to do so the alternatives are you
down you shrink down and put yourself in
a tight space that you're not yourself
and you live your life that way and it
sucks let me just tell you that and for
me you're probably wondering why is this
woman wearing a cat suit on eben
Carmichael's channel the reason for this
is because my it the thing that I wanted
to make it happen the it was for me to
be a kick-ass coach and an amazing
person in front of the camera but I was
holding myself back because I was so
scared that people would think I'm too
much for them because in my real
authentic life
so we're time and I'm a highly sexual
person I love talking about sex but yet
I hold myself back because I'm afraid
that people are gonna judge me because I
box myself into this little mold that I
shouldn't be like that because I'm a
personal development coach which means I
have to play it safe and not swear and
not Western alphas not show too much
cleavage because the people are gonna
see me as a sexual being
so during a conversation with Evan
yesterday it came to my realization that
I was sucking big time as a coach
because I was afraid to show myself who
I really am
and the reason for that is I think that
there is a certain version of how I
should be that I'm too concerned about
what the perfect model is to be a
personal development coach and if you
were to look at what Bill Gates was
talking about in the video he was seeing
when he was growing up the monolith was
IBM they were all about gigantic
computers big computers and here he was
this guy focused on personal computers
he who didn't allow that to hold him
back he didn't try to be somewhat he
wasn't because he was afraid of the
judgment of others because that could
have happened for him at the time when
he was growing up people like what are
you to go up against a monolith like IBM
maybe you should focus on big computers
but he said now because Bill Gates is a
badass that's what he is he went against
that and he said I'm gonna focus on
personal computers which is what
ultimately gave him the cutting edge
against other computer companies and now
of course he's a huge company so it's a
different situation altogether but we're
talking about how we started and for me
that's what I wanted to do I didn't
necessarily want to follow the normal
model because normal is born from yet
weird and I love that about myself and
yet I was holding myself back I was
holding myself back because I was afraid
of the judgment of others I was afraid
that if I come across too sexual people
are not going to focus on my message the
answer is not to cover myself up the
answer is to actually make my message
that much clearer and that much more
powerful and my message always has been
to really embrace who you truly are
however it looks like for you so I
accepted a challenge by putting myself
in a very hyper sexualized situation
which meant that I had to buy this cat
suit that I'm wearing right now do I
love rain cat suit no it is extremely
uncomfortable riding up my crotch and
it's hot in Toronto and it's not fun but
what does cat suit represents for me is
a permission the permission for me to
finally not follow the model that I've
been boxing myself in and actually be
myself it gives me the permission to
actually go out there and be the best
coach I can be and I cannot make it
happen
unless I actually just peel back the
layers and stop wearing a mask because
it sucks
it pisses me off that I have attracted a
lot of people because of the mask I was
wearing now I'm gonna lose a lot of
people because they're gonna see what
truly em it's a reality but that is a
lesson learned from me giving myself the
permission to wear this extremely weird
ass outfit I will never ever wear again
is giving me the permission to break the
mold and be myself so I could make it
happen from me
so I want to leave you all with this I
want you to write down the one thing
that you really want to do what you're
too afraid to do it because you've
afraid of the judgment of others you are
never going to win in life if you
continue to play small and stay safe
I hate saying better safe than sorry No
No you're going to be sorry if you play
it safe that's not what life is meant to
be life is meant for you to go out there
and do the things you really want to do
and that's how you're going to win both
in life and in business so please today
write down that one thing you really
want to do and I want to invite you to
make it even more challenging and make
it hyper uncomfortable for you make it
so uncomfortable that almost seems like
a caricature or what you will what you
always wanted to do like what I did in
this body suit I was so afraid to show a
little bit of cleavage in front of the
camera because I was afraid I might kind
of across as a sexual being so instead
what I did was how can I make this as
uncomfortable as possible is to go to a
sex shop and buy the cat suit because
now I've given myself the permission to
be who I really want to be so today is
your day your day to do something scary
that you're afraid to do and make it as
uncomfortable as possible because
everything else seemed like
because you deserve it you deserve to
have the life that you want but right
now you're to focus on the judgment of
others and it's scary okay
so it's time to peel back the layers and
do something for yourself for once and
make it happen now I got a special bonus
clip for you but before we get to that
the question of the day is what is that
one scary thing that you are going to do
today leave in the comments below I
don't join in on the discussion and
hopefully by you leaving in the comment
not only are you holding yourself
accountable but you have the entire
thing believe nation holding you
accountable because we got to start to
make happen thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you and I hope you
can need to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is and we'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso and now enjoy the bonus
clips
[Music]
I'd like you to fast-forward to 70 80 90
years old right fast forward in your
mind to that age 70 80 90 100 110 if
you're really optimistic whichever one
it is and I'd like you to write down
what will be the things that you'll
regret that you didn't do imagine you're
that age ask yourself the question what
would I regret that I didn't do know
what you did do but what you didn't do
write it down make a long list right now
get a pen and paper out and write it
down don't do on your phone don't do in
your laptop actually get a pen and paper
and write down your answers and what
will be the things that you regret that
you didn't do right really think about
it would it be you know learning a new
language will it be moving home will it
be telling someone you love them what
will it be what would have been write it
down right now now the incredible thing
about this question is that you're using
the future to empower the past whatever
answer you have in that question
whatever your answer is you can do it
right now today starting today because
you're not that agent and if you're even
if you're 64 and you're tuning in 70 80
90 you're still there right it's still
possible you can start doing that right
now it's empowering the present with the
future there is nothing stopping you
from making it happen right now you
don't have to feel that way when you're
70 you don't have to feel that way when
you're 80 you never ever have to feel
that way if you start doing it right now
and you can do it right now even if it
feels impossible you can stop working on
it right now you can start trying right
now you can start making plans right now
because you're not there yet and this is
where you start this is where you start
making it happen it's all in the now
people see the idea of being
entrepreneurs or being their own bosses
are building their own empires this
thing that you know you need investments
you need all these people need that flip
flip right look if this sock costs $5 to
make we sell it for $20 you make $15
flip with rocking you know I was trying
to give a rocky for a long time she said
and you know Puerto Rican girls they
can't bring black boys home old school
you know I'm saying right
so it took a minute you know saying well
and she was telling me curve balls left
and right and so one of her curve balls
was you know I see you put all these
other people on you know I see you make
all these other people's dreams come
true but you like to make movies I can't
get with you unless you stand behind
what you love and I was like all right
you know I had to you know I mean she
called me out you know I'm saying Seoul
was like you know I can't have a woman
or a girl I want to be my woman calling
me out but also it made perfect sense it
was true I was unconsciously probably
standing behind other people instead of
standing behind myself all I do is get
somebody and tell them how to get it and
you know make the things that are wrong
right but if I could make the things
that are wrong right for somebody else
why not sell me you know understand like
even down to the diabetes I'm like yo
yeah we do a whole network on diabetes
something that's usually considered a
weakness I'd prefer to turn it into a
strength it's about me firstly I
wouldn't say I was broke do you
understand I was broke when I was 25
dead broke I'm not talking about
financially broke let me tell you
something no I didn't have any money in
my pocket I didn't have any credit cards
nobody would give me credit okay didn't
have a driver's license okay 1970 Ford
Maverick had a 1970 Ford Maverick no air
no heat no door handles the freaking
floor was rusted okay I lived in a 275
square foot apartment maybe 300 square
feet if he counted a little step out in
the front
or pay 275 a month and I was late almost
every month
so don't tell me about your money
problems man okay don't tell me about
where you were born
don't tell me about your bad brakes
don't tell me about what your daddy did
or your uncle felt you up or something
just some kind of weird thing too you
know I'll ruin your head or your sister
abused you or whatever okay
look we all got problems you got to fix
your problems now you got to get your
money right so 25 years old I'm like I'm
getting my money right I'm done no more
excuses no more crybaby no more blame
I'm getting my freaking money right now
turistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what gary vee DJ khalid
oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video